what is the difference between a between
subject design and a within subject
design and why is it important to know
the difference this is what we discussed
in this video let's start with an
example let's assume you want to find
out if vacations have an effect on
people's stress levels in order to
analyze this question you've prepared a
small questionnaire to measure people's
stress levels with a questionnaire you
now ask people before and after the
vacation about the stress level so you
have two variables stress level and
vacation vacation has the two levels
before and after vacation now there are
two possible research designs number one
you interview people before they go on
vacation and then interview other people
after the vacation in this case you
would have a between subject design
because the people you interviewed
before the vacation have nothing to do
with with the people you interviewed
after the vacation the second and in
this case better design would be you
interview people before they go on
vacation and then interview the same
people after the vacation in this case
you would have a within subject design
the measured values are always available
in pairs and the same subject is exposed
to both levels of the factor therefore
in a between subject design each subject
or participant is only assigned to one
factor level so that the different
subjects only have the influence of the
respective group in contrast in within
subject design the same subjects or
participants are exposed to all Factor
levels which enables a direct comparison
of the reactions to each factor level
you therefore have a within subject
design if you interview one and the same
person at two time points once before
and once after a certain event the pairs
for example arise from repeated
measurements on the same individuals of
course there does not necessarily have
to be a before after relationship that
is being studied a within subject design
also exists if for example you want to
test whether a new type of baseball bat
has an effect on the results of a
baseball game and you let the same
people play once with the old bat and
once with the new one then the measured
values are also available in pairs each
player has used both bats and therefore
there are two measured values from each
player and it doesn't even have to be
the same person for example if you
wanted to find out whether in a couple
between men and women women do more
gardening than men do you would also
have a within subject design and of
course it doesn't have to be about
people you could also investigate
whether a lubricant has an influence on
the downtime of machines then you would
have measured values from the machines
with the old and then with a new
lubricant the data is then also
available in pairs between subject
design in case of a between subject
design each subject is only assigned to
one of the two groups for example if the
group of men and a group of women are
asked about their income
independent samples are available of
course in a between subject design and
within subject design there can also be
more than two groups in other words the
factor to be analyzed can have more than
two levels let's look at this using an
anova as an example let's say we want to
test whether different diets have an
effect on cholesterol levels we would
like to compare the three diets a b and
c so the factor Di diet has the three
levels a b and c to test whether there
is a difference between the diets we are
conducting a study with 18 participants
the individual participants are called
subjects now we randomly assign six
participants to each of the three groups
each participant or subject is assigned
to only one group in this case we have a
between subjects Factor different
subjects are exposed to different levels
of a factor in this analysis our
objective is to determine whether
significant differences exist in the
mean cholesterol levels among the
various groups on study and this is
exactly what a one way an NOA does now
of course we could also examine the
impact of one diet across multiple time
points we could measure the cholesterol
levels at each participant at the start
of the diet after 2 weeks and after 4
weeks so the factor time has the three
levels start two weeks and four weeks
and in this case the same subjects being
exposed to all levels of the factor so
we have a within subject Factor the same
subjects are exposed to all levels or
conditions in this case we want to know
if there is a difference in the mean
value of the cholesterol levels between
the different points in time and this is
exactly what a repeated measures Anova
does therefore in a repeated measures
and NOA we have within subject factors
therefore in a between subject design
each subject or participant is only
assigned to one factor level so that the
different subjects only have the
influence of the respective group in
contrast in a within subjects design the
same subjects or participants are
exposed to all Factor levels which
enables a direct comparison of their
reactions to each factor level but what
if you want to test if there is a
difference between Diet a b and c over
the different points in time so we want
to test if there is a difference between
the diets and if there is difference
between the different time points then
we need a mixed model and Nova because
we have both one between subject factor
and one within subject Factor so in a
mixed modan NOA we have at least one
between subjects factor and at least one
within subjects factor in the same
analysis therefore the mixed model and
NOA tests whether there is a difference
between more than two samples which are
divided at least between two factors one
of the factors is a result of
measurement repetition as we have just
seen you need different hypothesis tests
depending on whether you use a between
subject design or a within subject
design if you use a between subject
design for example an independent
samples T Test or a oneway Nova is used
if you use a within subject design for
example a paired samples T Test or a
repeated measures Anova is used but
don't worry data will help you find the
right hypothesis test I'll show you how
to do that now just visit data.net and
copy your data into this table let's say
this is the data we want to analyze here
we have a factor with therapy a b and
see and we have measured cholesterol
levels at three different times if we
click on before and end a paired samples
T Test is calculated because we want to
know if there is a difference between
the two points before and end if we
click on all three time points a
repeated measures and NOA is automatic
calculated and if we click on therapy
and end we have a between subjects
design and a oneway and NOA is
calculated we want to know if there is a
difference between the three Therapies
in terms of cholesterol
levels of course we can also select all
variables and then a mixed model and NOA
will be
calculated thanks for watching and I
hope you enjoyed the
video